l'entreprise la littorale de Bézier
devrait pouvoir continuer ses activités
cette entreprise vous le savez est la
seule en France à utiliser l'isocianate
de méthyl on avait interdit la
manipulation de ce produit hautement
toxique à la suite de la catastrophe de
beupal en Inde aujourd'hui les autorités
administratives ont donné leur accord
pour que le composant des insecticides
arrive déjà mélangé à Bézier cependant
cela ne lève pas toutes les hypothèques
sur l'avenir de la littorale Jacques
la 3ème réunion aura été la bonne après
de convocations veaines faute de
participants en nombre suffisant ce
matin le conseil d'hygiène de l'éau a
donné le feu vert un avis favorable
quant à l'importation de l'aldicarb
substitut de l'isoccianate de mythyle
pour la fabrication du thémic un avis
qui n'étonnera personne 400 emplois
seraient en effet supprimé à Bier en cas
d'interdiction d'importation de cette
aldicarb en France et quel responsable
pourrait prendre en ce moment une telle
décision le produit pourrait arriver en
France dans les 3 semaines sans qu'il
soit certain que le chômage technique
soit évité complètement le principal
obstacle administratif est donc levé en
France certes mais l'acheminement ne se
fera qu'après la publication aux USA du
rapport d'enquête décidé après la fuite
de l'usine américaine
d'institute le conseil d'hygiène après
une longue réunion qui a duré 2 he a
donné une vie favorable aux nouvelles
dispositions de fabrication du thémic
est-ce que cet avis bon sans doute
sera-t-il suivi des fait bien entendu
mais est-ce que pour autant ce cette
fabrication pourra continuer compte tenu
des incertitudes qui pèsent aux
États-Unis sur les résultats de
l'enquête en cours des explications très
précises ont été donné sur l'incident
qui est intervenu aux États-Unis et le
système de fabrication est un système
différent est-ce trahir le secret des
débats que de vous demander s'il y a
unanimité euh quasi unanimité la
longueur des débat il a une quasi
unanimité mais la longueur de débat
s'explique par le sérieux de l'examen
qui a été fait et sérieux qui est bien
nécessaire je précise d'ailleurs que des
dispositions très sérieuses seront
également prises pour ce qui est du
transport des matières brutes entre
Marseille et B